S
TORE TALENT.
WE HAVE ALL OVERESTIMATED OUR
ABILITY.
WATCHING DO SOMETHING ON TV AND
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE THINK WE CAN
DO IT BETTER.
[SCREAMS]
IF WE ARE LUCKY SOMEONE WILL
COME AND TELL US WE ARE IN WAY
OVER OUR HEADS.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN
TRYING TO GET THAT POINT ACROSS
TO JOE BIDEN FOR OVER A YEAR AND
A HALF TELLING HIM HE IS JUST
NOT THAT GUY ANYMORE.
HE CAN'T BE GOING OUT IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERAS LIKE HE USED TO,
YOU KNOW, BACK IN THE DAY.
AND FOR SOME TIME JOE LISTENED
HE SPENT 221 DAYS WITHOUT A
SIT-DOWN INTERVIEW SITTING DOWN
IN BUNKER WHILE MOST OF US HAD
QUESTIONS.
JOE BIDEN DECIDED TO FINALLY
BREAK THAT STREAK THIS WEEKEND
TALKING TO "60 MINUTES" AND TRY
TO PROVE TO EVERYONE THAT HE
STILL HAS IT IN HIM.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, YOU ARE THE
OLDEST PRESIDENT EVER.
>> PRETTY GOOD SHAPE, EH?
>> WHICH LEADS TO THE NEXT
QUESTION.
SOME PEOPLE ASK WHETHER YOU ARE
FIT FOR THE JOB AND WHEN YOU
HEAR THAT I WONDER WHAT YOU
THINK.
>> WATCH ME.
HONEST TO GOD THAT'S ALL I
THINK.
WATCH ME.
>> Jesse: WE HAVE BEEN WATCHING.
THAT'S WHY SCOTT PELLEY ASKED
YOU THAT AND WE DON'T LIKE WHAT
WE SEE.
BIDEN IS LIKE THE GUY GOING
AROUND TELLING YOU HOW GREAT OF
SHAPE HE IS IN.
>> CHECK MY SHAPE.
LET'S DO PUSHUP TOGETHERS.
LET'S ROLL, DO WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO DO.
>> Jesse: IF THE PRESIDENT WAS
ALL ABOUT DOING PUSHUPS, WE
WOULD ELECT MR. T WHOSE FISCAL
POLICY I'M A LITTLE UNCLEAR
ABOUT.
BUT THE PRESIDENCY IS ABOUT THE
MUSCLE BETWEEN YOUR EARS.
>> HOW WOULD YOU SAY YOUR MENTAL
FOCUS IS?
>> IT'S FOCUSED.
[LAUGHTER]
LOOK, I HAVE TROUBLE EVEN
MENTIONING AND EVEN SAYING TO MY
HEAD THE NUMBER OF YEARS.
I NO MORE THINKING OF MYSELF
BEING AS OLD AS I AM THAN FLY.
>> Jesse: DID YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT THAT WAS?
I HAVE NO IDEA WHAT HE SAID.
NO IDEA.
THE PROBLEM IS INTERVIEWS LIKE
THIS FOR JOE IS YOU CAN'T HAND
HIM NOTE CARDS LIKE THEY USUALLY
DO TO TELL HIM WHAT TO DO OR
WHAT TO SAY.
THERE'S NO TELEPROMPTER EITHER
LOOK HOW UNPREPARED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WAS FOR A FRIENDLY INTERVIEW.
MAKES TOTAL SENSE HOW HE DIDN'T
SEE INFLATION COMING.
HE DIDN'T SEE THIS COMING.
HE WASN'T PREPARED FOR A
QUESTION ABOUT THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE IN THE COUNTRY.
WATCH.
>> LAST TUESDAY, THE ANNUAL
INFLATION RATE CAME IN AT 8.3%,
PHIL, PUT IN THIS PERSPECTIVE.
THE INFLATION RATE WAS UNJUST AN
INCH, HARDLY AT ALL.
>> YOU ARE NOT ARGUING THAT 8.3
IS GOOD NEWS.
>> NO I'M NOT SAYING IT WAS GOOD
NEWS.
IT WAS 8.2 OR 8.2 BEFORE.
YOU MAKE IT SOUND LIKE ALL OF A
SUDDEN MY GOD IT WENT TO 8.2%.
>> IT'S THE HIGHEST INFLATION
RATE, MR. PRESIDENT, IN 40
YEARS.
>> I GOT THAT.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK HE DOES
JOE BIDEN IS ARGUING 8.2 OR 8.3.
NOBODY CARES ABOUT 8.2.
NOBODY CARES.
JUST A NUMBER.
THEY SAY JOE BIDEN'S GREATEST
ASSET IS HIS EMPATHY.
SHOW US YOUR ASSET FEEL OUR
PAIN, MR. PRESIDENT.
WE ARE STRUGGLING OUT HERE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
ARGUING THE NUMBERS?
TELL US YOU ARE SORRY AND YOU
ARE GOING TO FIX IT AND YOU SEE
THE LIGHT AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL.
I WILL COULD DO THAT JOE BIDEN
THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE A GOOD IDEA
TO TELL CHINA WE ARE GOING TO
WAR.
>> WHAT SHOULD CHINESE PRESIDENT
XI KNOW ABOUT YOUR COMMITMENT TO
TAIWAN IF U.S. FORCES DEFEND THE
ISLAND.
>> YES IF UNPRECEDENTED ATTACK
IT.
>> AFTER OUR INTERVIEW WHITE
HOUSE OFFICIAL TOLD US U.S.
POLICY HAS NOT CHANGED.
OFFICIALLY THE U.S. WILL NOT SAY
WHETHER AMERICAN FORCES WOULD
DEFEND TAIWAN IS.
>> IS IT ME OR DO YOU GET THE
FEELING JOE BIDEN IS NOT REALLY
THE PRESIDENT.
WHO IS THIS UNNAMED U.S.
OFFICIAL?
IS HE PRESIDENT?
JOE BIDEN IS THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
HE IS SUPPOSED TO SET FOREIGN
POLICY.
WHEN HE GOES OUT THERENNED A
SETS IT, THERE IS SOMEONE ELSE
BEHIND THE CURTAIN SAYING NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO.
THAT'S NOT REALLY WHAT OUR
POLICY IS?
WHAT?
WHY THE WAY HE SAID THE PANDEMIC
IS OVER BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T
WEAR MASKS ANYMORE.
>> IS THE PANDEMIC OVER?
>> THE PANDEMIC IS OVER, WE
STILL HAVE A PROBLEM WITH COVID
STILL DOING A LOT OF WORK ON IT.
THE PANDEMIC IS OVER.
IF YOU NOTICE, NO ONE IS WEARING
MASKS, EVERYBODY SEEMS TO BE IN
PRETTY GOOD SHAPE I THINK IT'S
CHANGING.
>> Jesse: FIRST OF ALL BIDEN IS
WALKING AROUND WEARK A MASK ALL
THE TIME LIKE LITERALLY LAST
WEEK HE IS OUTSIDE WEARING A
MASK.
SECOND OF ALL, HE IS STILL
FIRING PEOPLE FOR NOT BEING
VAXXED.
THIRD, DID JOE BIDEN TELL FAUCI
THE PANDEMIC WAS OVER?
LET'S CHECK IN AND SEE HOW THE
GOOD DOCTOR IS TAKING THE NEWS.
>> YOU ARE ENTIRELY AND
COMPLETELY INCORRECT.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT.
HOW ARE POLL NUMBERS SO BAD IF
HE CRUSHED THE VIRUS?
>> YOU HAVE HAD A STRING OF
LEGISLATIVE SUCCESSES RECENTLY.
>> HOW DOES DO THAT?
>> BUT, YOUR APPROVAL RATING IN
THE COUNTRY IS WELL BELOW 50% I
WONDER WHY YOU THINK THAT.
>> IS.
>> I THINK YOU WOULD AGREE THAT
THE IMPACT ON THE PSYCHE OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AS A CONSEQUENCE
OF THE PANDEMIC IS PROFOUND.
>> Jesse: SO, JOE BIDEN SAYS HE
IS UNPOPULAR BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC THAT HE CRUSHED?
YOU CRUSHED COVID, INFLATION IS
NOT BAD AND GOING TO WAR WITH
CHINA.
ARE YOU COMMITTED TO RUNNING
AGAIN?
>> SIR, ARE YOU COMMITTED TO
RUNNING AGAIN?
I TAKE IT THE DECISION HAS NOT
BEEN MADE IN YOUR OWN HEAD.
>> LOOK, MY INTENTION AS I SAID
TO BEGIN WITH IS THAT I WOULD
RUN AGAIN BUT IT'S JUST AN
INTENTION.
BUT IS IT A FIRM DECISION?
THAT I WOULD RUN AGAIN?
THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
>> Jesse: THAT ANSWER TELLS ME
IT'S NOT EVEN UP TO BIDEN
WHETHER HE RUNS AGAIN.
SOMEONE IS GOING TO TELL JOE IF
HE IS RUNNING OR NOT RUNNING AND
HE IS JUST GOING TO DO WHATEVER
THEY TELL HIM.
REMEMBER, JILL BIDEN DOESN'T
EVEN KNOW IF JOE IS RUNNING AND
THEY SLEEP TOGETHER.
OBVIOUSLY BOTH OF THEM HAVEN'T
BEEN TOLD.
MAYBE IT'S THE UNNAMED U.S.
OFFICIAL THAT WILL TELL HIM.
AT THIS RATE BE JOE BIDEN CAN'T
TELL IF HE IS RUNNING FOR
RE-ELECTION IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
WALK IT BACK.
OFFICIAL U.S. POLICY CO-WORKER
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN REMAINS
UNCHANGED.
IF YOU LISTEN CLOSELY, CAN YOU
ALMOST HEAR GAVIN NEWSOM
CELEBRATING
♪
>> Jesse: AND THEN CBS STARTED
FEELING A LITTLE NOSTALGIC
REMINISCING OVER THE DAYS WHEN
BIDEN COULD PAL AROUND WITH
SEGREGATIONISTS AND THROW BACK A
FEW BOURBON.
>> WHAT WE THINK ABOUT TODAY,
THINK ABOUT IT, ALL PERSONAL
ATTACKS MOTIVE.
NOT IF I DISAGREE WITH YOU ON
THE SUBJECT MATTER.
>> IT SEEMS TO ME,
MR. PRESIDENT, THAT WHEN YOU
WERE FIRST CAME TO THE SENATE
THE OTHER GUY HAD A BAD IDEA NOW
THE OTHER GUY IS A BAD GUY.
>> YEAH.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU GET
BACK.
>> HERE'S THE THING WHEN JOE
BIDEN CALLS THE HALF OF THE
NATION NEANDERTHALS HARD TO
WOMAN BACK.
>> STILL HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT
RECORD BREAKING CRIME AND
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
CBS COULDN'T LEAVE WITHOUT
ASKING ABOUT HUNTER AND PELLEY'S
QUESTION WAS, OF COURSE, YOU
KNOW THE REPUBLICANS ARE GOING
TO POUNCE MR. PRESIDENT, IF YOU
RUN AGAIN, REPUBLICANS ARE MOST
LIKELY TO GO AFTER YOUR SON
HUNTER ONCE AGAIN.
>> I LOVE MY SON.
NUMBER ONE, HE FOUGHT ADDICTION
PROBLEM.
HE WROTE ABOUT IT.
NOT A SINGLE THING I HAVE
OBSERVED AT ALL THAT WOULD
EFFECT ME OR THE UNITED STATES
RELATIVE TO MY SON HUNTER.
>> Jesse: SO I LOVE MY DRUG
ADDICT SON AND I DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING WRONG.
NO FOLLOW-UP.
THAT WAS IT.
NOW, WHY DID YOU LIE ABOUT
HUNTER NOT MAKING ANY MONEY IN
CHINA?
WHY DID YOU NOT KNOWING ABOUT
HUNTER BIDEN'S DEALS?
ARE YOU THE BIG GUY?
CBS DIDN'T ASK ANY OF THAT.
NOT EVEN ANYTHING ABOUT THE
STORY THAT CBS BROKE ABOUT THE
150 SUSPICIOUS TREASURY
TRANSACTIONS OF THE BIDEN
FAMILY.
REMEMBER WHEN TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT.
CBS WAS PART OF THE
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
>> I THINK IT'S ONE OF THE
BIGGEST SCANDALS I HAVE EVER
SEEN AND YOU DON'T COVER IT.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
>> BECAUSE IT CAN'T BE VERIFIED.
I'M TELLING YOU.
>> YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
INSIGNIFICANT THINGS.
>> I'M TELLING.
>> YOU OF COURSE IT CAN BE
VERIFIED.
EXCUSE ME, THEY FOUND THE
LAPTOP.
>> IT CAN'T BE VERIFIED.
>> WHAT CAN'T BE VERIFIED?
>> THE LAPTOP.
>> Jesse: YEAH.
IT WAS VERIFIED.
THE ONLY THING THAT CAN'T BE
VERIFIED RIGHT NOW IS WHO IS IN
CHARGE OF THE COUNTRY.
EVERY FAIR MINDED PERSON WHO SAW
THAT INTERVIEW KNOWS JOE BIDEN
CAN'T BE PRESIDENT.
I CAN PRETEND TO BE A DEMOCRAT
AND ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS
BETTER.
I MIGH